swamped this is a suburb of maribyrnong
in Melbourne's West just 10 kilometers
from the Heart of the City the
maribyrnong river burst its banks
hundreds of homes are underwater others
have been isolated 50 000 people across
the state are without power
this is my family home my father built
this house and lived here most of my
life and yeah it's never been watering
it before
two days of unrelenting rain caused
flash flooding across Melbourne
thousands of people in Victoria were
told to leave those who were stranded
were rescued by emergency service Crews
we still are of the view that there's
about 500 homes that have been inundated
there are another 500 Homes at least
that have been isolated so when I say
homes properties maybe more than just a
house maybe in terms of Farmland much
bigger Parcels of land
evacuation orders were issued across
three states in Western New South Wales
highways and Rail lines have been cut
off in the state of Tasmania rainfall
records have been broken after two days
of torrential rain
this is the second major flood event
this year with Queensland and New South
Wales devastated by what was described
as a rain bomb in February this year and
it's not expected to be the last the
Bureau of meteorology has warned that a
la linea weather event will bring with
it heavy rainfall over summer
the worst of the rain may have passed
but authorities say some river systems
are expected to peak in the coming days
and then there's the cleanup
Sarah Clark Al Jazeera Brisbane
Australia